I feel like you've grown up in young
Hollywood really having like so many
successful shows and now you're on arrow
do you feel a responsibility with that
platform I do actually and it's
something that I've known for a long
time but especially through shadow
ventures because the fandom is so vocal
and it and so many people who are going
through a very transitional time in
their lives have become attached to the
show and any show has become a tool for
them in a vessel for them and the fandom
has become the community where they can
feel loved and accepted and and feel
free to be exactly where as they are so
I think we do have a responsibility
because we are in the public eye and
because our society has become one in
which media is very influential we have
to at least try and make a mark on the
world in some way because yes we get to
do what we love for a living but it
gives us a bit of a voice and I'm
determined not to waste mine so yeah I
mean I try not to tell people what to
think or how to be but I try and just
put positivity out into the world and
nobody's perfect but at least I can try
and make someone smile when in a while
how has the aro fandom and grace to you
I mean me finally not we are playing
it's very exciting it's very interesting
I was so nervous very excited but so
nervous because well because I've seen
through you know with Malick being right
next to olicity and so many of these
articles and everything I know how
beloved they are to the fandom and I
know what that means to these people
that have been watching the show from
day one
I just want to do right by that right
but I really I'm loving the way this
character is being crafted and the way
things are kind of unfolding and now
that I can find the top about it it's a
sigh of relief
ya know but it's it's really wonderful
and they've been so welcoming and I'm
starting to see fan art now it's amazing
you know that there's like a forward
like a future episode what can you tease
about that Oh what can I teach that's
using too much uh you get to see a lot
about Waimea is the way she is and what
in her childhood and what events in her
life up until this point have happened
to form her into this hardened fighter
into this person that doesn't feel with
emotions well doesn't deal with
vulnerability well and has really
guarded herself what is it like having
Steven and Emily really as your parents
on the show extremely intimidating but
incredibly wonderful as well because
well when best-first called me and told
me who actually was she goes yeah um so
intellectually we want her to have all
of the best qualities of Felicity but
physically we want her to have all the
qualities of Oliver I'm going so to
salmon water or the 12 pack or what what
what do I need to do no but both Stephen
and Emily is in so lovely and really
welcoming and so just helpful um I also
watch the entire series to try and do
index wood because they've done such a
wonderful job crafting these characters
and I feel like it's my job to carry
that on
finale season the final season of
Shadowhunters what can you reveal about
it put the band mine to rest well I'm in
the show even though I'm technically
dead right now I'm in I'm in the episode
and there but what I can say is that
particularly about Clara's journey she's
been trying to push aside that
Morganstern half of her the half of her
that her father brought this darkness as
evil this sort of stain on on her
reputation and on who she is and on her
soul innocence and she didn't kill her
father after all so it's something that
she's tried to push aside and the events
that happened in 3d for certain confront
them head on and it's something that she
is forced to reconcile with that part of
her and that part of her family and find
it would be positive and the negative
sides of facing who it is the early are
the fans you know the fandom it's I mean
they're amazing they've put up
billboards trying to save this show do
you have a message to them the biggest
thing I can say is just thank you I'm
constantly astounded and humbled and
eternally grateful as a shadow fan
even a small part of this community
they've created it has just been the
biggest gift and hearing the stories and
seeing what people have created because
of the show it's really astounding I I
just love the fact that in this world
that's so divided there's a group out
there that is all about loves and all
about helping each other and that just
gives me hope for the future
[Music]